hello
we're back
lots of news went on while we were apart
pete davidson and kim kardashian are
still together
it's the couple that makes me ask would
world war three be such a bad thing
but we've been off for a few weeks and
for good reason this is a news channel
and war is news actually it's breaking
news and it's breaking all the time but
you can't spell breaking news without a
break and sometimes we do need a break
but first let's assess what we know
so
ukraine is a country in europe it exists
next to another country called russia
russia is a bigger country russia is a
powerful country russia decided to
invade a smaller country called ukraine
so
basically that's wrong
you know
i love how she speaks to me
like i have a head injury
maybe i do
but it's true russia invaded ukraine and
like joe biden reading a children's book
what assumed would take days is now
nearly a month
and with every passing day things just
get more desperate
now meanwhile
my mother-in-law escaped from ukraine to
poland and no she didn't write out on
her broom
she got out with the help of some very
amazing people which i'll get into in a
second but now my wife is out there in
warsaw trying to figure out a way for
her mom to get home which means
i'm all alone
but i've been trying to keep busy you
know
it's been really tough
but i've managed to make some
sympathetic friends
look i had to do something
changing all the locks on the doors of
the apartment only took about an hour
but in all seriousness thanks to fox i
was able to get my mother-in-law out of
calf it's a pretty amazing tale they
picked her up in a small village and
drove for hours days even and was able
to get her out of danger in poland i
believe they did this so i could use my
new mother-in-law jokes
for example my mother-in-law was stuck
in kiev
and it posed a dilemma get her out or
block her on facebook
yes
dead silence but seriously my wife
wanted me to send somebody in to get her
i would have but i have a one-star
rating on uber
my mother-in-law was stuck in kiev and
to be honest i'm not crazy about her so
after hours of arguing about it we came
to an agreement if rescued i'm back in
her will
wow
but enough
in all honesty she made an insane trek
across the country and made it out alive
thanks to a hearty band of fox news
employees who didn't even know her but
offered to help i mean who knew dagen
mcdowell knew how to make molotov
cocktails out of hand sanitizer and a
bottle of prel
and who knew cat could drink those
here is my mother-in-law reunited with
her daughter my wife elena i haven't
seen my wife that happy since i moved
into the guest room
but i have fox news's scott wilder trey
yingst and steve harrigan among others
to thank for this
so it's obvious the war in ukraine is an
ugly bloody thing it's also a war
between competing narratives some are
persuasive but also confusing in this
new fog of war
it's always two movies on one screen
ukraine is fighting and winning and
russia is about to crush them hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else